it was a cold start to the week in
Poland's Capital but for some a hopeful
beginning of a new political era uh yes
I'm happy with the election I took part
in the hope that finally something will
change in
Poland I expect that women will have
more rights that they will feel safer
that they will be more
appreciated in the aftermath of the
country's parliamentary election it was
the ruling Law And Justice party that
seemed to have G G the most votes but it
was the opposition liberal Coalition
that appears headed for a majority in
Parliament led by former prime minister
and former president of the European
Council Donald Tusk called the vote the
most important since the fall of
communism a significant turning point
after 8 years of nationalist rule during
which Poland the largest European Union
member in Central and Eastern Europe has
clashed frequently with Brussels this a
period of taking Poland to the margins
of Europe of uh breaking rule of law
rules of democracy this is ending uh the
ruling party has no um Coalition
capacity so I'm sure that within the
next few weeks the current opposition
will be forming the
government the record voter turnout had
spurred on supporters of the opposition
Coalition but there is still uncertainty
over how such a government would
function with an ally of the law and
Justice party as president while its
Representatives still maintain a sizable
presence in Parliament Sonia Gago Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer